eh c'est les vacances et cette année
j'ai découvert la grèce j'ai eu cette
chance
je ne pouvais pas ne pas faire des
vidéos est normal ouais ça c'est le
drapeau de la grèce et je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai toujours pensé que ça
c'était le drapeau de la fin à l'entente
du coup le premier jour où j'arrivais
anglaise
j'ai dit mais pourquoi il met des
drapeaux de la finlande partout là ça
n'a aucun sens c'est marrant parce que
quand j'ai annoncé à mes potes que
j'allais dans la ville de mykonos en
grèce
ils m'ont tous fait la même blague bien
lourde ah ouais tu vois dans la ville
des ou comme je voulais pas trop
qui le malentendu après quand me
demander où j'allais en vacances je
répondais je vais aux états unis dans un
état très hétérosexuels par exemple le
texas là où il ya plein de cow boy très
viril away des cowboys
un peu comme dans le film brokeback
mountain non c'est pas les mêmes tu vois
je suis du nord de la france
je suis gentil et quand je suis arrivé
dans la ville de mykonos j'ai fait un
rapprochement dans la tête et lui aussi
à merde je suis un ch'ti à mykonos
à
[Musique]
waouh
comme tous les bon d'accord ce qui est
incroyable chez les grecs ce que quand
ils font du scooter ils portent pas de
casque et abandonné j'ai loué un scooter
pendant une journée et j'ai loué un
casque aussi parce que pour la sécurité
puis parce que je suis habitué et quand
les grecs m'ont vu avec mon casque
il m'a regardé comme si j'étais un
extraterrestre même les policiers grecs
regardez un peu chelou obama c'est quoi
ça ben c'est un casque ok ne bouge et
surtout pas appel à toutes les unités
un malade mental se promène dans mykonos
avec une boule sur la tête et certaines
langues comme l'espagnol l'italien
l'anglais ou même si tu parles pas
forcément la langue là tu comprends un
peu certains noms en grèce il utilise un
alphabet vous comprends pas du tout un
qui n'existent pas du tout chez nous ce
qui est assez handicapant quand tu as
besoin de faire des choix
bon ben on entre et je vais prendre bon
bah au hasard allez je vais prendre ça
d'accord le monsieur ah ouais je me suis
peut-être trompé le magasin en fait en
grèce il fait vraiment très chaud c'est
à dire qu'ils vont te pose un pied
dehors
ton qui brûle mais ça a quand même
certains aspects un peu pratique
avez vous une bonne douche froide ah non
c'est bon je suis avec les grecs pour
attirer les gens dans leur restaurant
il faut un truc assez mal à un street
ouvre l'appétit il donne vraiment envie
de manger
des cadavres de poules peu mort c'est
vrai que ça donne faim
évidemment la question que tout le monde
se pose est que je me suis aussi posé
est ce que les 112 y un lead cabab comme
certains l'appellent sont meilleures en
grèce qu'en france est ce qu'ils ont
l'air plus appétissant correction sur le
rouleau j'y suis allé et j'ai eu la
réponse
d'abord il ya vraiment des milliers de
guêpe des vrais gates un des
rigueur qui te piquent font très très
mal
et ben y en a partout sauf que les grecs
eux ils sont habitués à ça ça leur pose
aucun problème ça les dérange pas
d'avoir des animaux ici qui doivent
peut-être les tuer les le temps de
relever le taux bas âge avec tous des
feuillages
j'aime beaucoup la balle et manger des
kebabs tous d'accord d'accord ligue de
l'ouest patch pas intéressé bien 36000
guerre autour de moi là cinq étapes en
guerre c'est un frelon assez un frelon
adacore autant pour moi dans ce cas là
pas de souci si tranquille au tailgate
pava et ouais tous les goûts de l'axé
marseille et la part de tous mes amis de
myspace merci d'avoir regardé ma vidéo
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne youtube et moi me reste plus qu'à
vous dire au revoir avec le seul mot que
je connais en grec kke à l'iml mais ça
va là bas ils contractent c'est facile
moi si je contracte c'est pareil c'est
nazi contracte mais j'ai pu contracter
maintenant si mon spectacle normal
scène commence à partir de septembre en
tournée dans toute la galaxie est aussi
à chalon sur saône pour venir me voir
cliquer sur le lien dans la description